simon's crosses goes to the body of
walker nice plays he turns and finds
merck at the rim he'll dump it in
greg brown back in
mclemore is in simon's and
watford looks low in the corner
simon's into the lane running righty up
and in they swing it here to brown off
into the corner to mclemore he's trapped
simon's gives him a way out with nine to
shoot he will
and drill to three
fournier from the corner no air ball
grab by winslow on the push he's got a
man ahead it's mclemore all the way to
the cup for the easy two-hand jab
lasers beating the lakers 107 105 you
hear chancey phillips laughing
out there on the floor with them happens
to be on the sideline though instead of
having a uniform
macklemore picks a pass
swings it up to simons for the two-hand
jam
so
simon's with 20
eight assists
blazers pulled him within 15 after
trailing by 23. outside is alex burks
brownie tracked it all the way he went
helicoptering over traffic to lay it in
with a left hand
so train them was down there too so
greg had to
deal with julius randle go over the top
of him first and then go over the top of
trending second
hand
there's a little hot potato outside of
watford over the mclemore he's got five
to shoot on the way to the glass laid it
in and it all worked out just fine
he's got one to give
mark to three
[Music]
[Applause]
but thanks for cleaning that up
[Applause]
mark will bring it out of that court
crosses over goes right to the cup lays
it and he is fouled
how often do you see him have to stop
and then make a move and then maybe make
another move it rarely happens
because he waits for the right time to
attack
and he's so quick he's always low to the
ground
[Applause]
[Applause]
red ground cut through so now elijah
it's all you left side do what you want
with it three ball line it up
kippah walker during the break comes in
along with randall and grimes ann gibson
and fournier randall steps back and
scores that's a good shot
there you go numbers
part on the push he's going to go right
to the right
walker and lays it in
boy dips in like he's gonna go to the
right
gets kimball walker to bounce that
direction and then the gap is there
outside simons for three yes sir there
it is
anthony simon's 23 on the afternoon five
of ten from three that defensive play
doesn't show up in a box score but those
are the kind of plays he makes
simon's outside for a triple no winslow
prize it free in traffic finds mclemore
floats a three got it
ben mclemore was the guy simon's off the
high screen he'll penetrate one lays it
up and him with a little friendly spin
he's fouled
the blazers have a chance to take the
lead with 4 30 left in the fourth
quarter
simons enters to winslow nerd makes the
cut there's that cut the blazers on the
dive and nerf with the jam and the
blazers leader rand randall along with
quinton grimes and fournier in opposite
corners
alec burks on the dribble drive out to
randall had an ocean from three he'll
drive and kick burks triggers a three
and got it
simons will bring it across waits for
nerd to screen off the action he
elevates
and pumps in
[Applause]
[Music]
23 and the ball movement was gorgeous
[Applause]
boy listen to the crowd
that's a good move that's a good move
simons goes back to the lab lasers by
three
simon's on the interchange with dirk he
got into the ear
he was ripped down by 48 he was able to
play through and lay it home and the
blazers lead by five blazers lead is
five simon's eludes finds mclemore for
three no rebound up the fingertips and
wins those grabbed by nerf he's in the
paint he gives off the winslow banks and
scores
and the blazers lead at 110 103. was the
right decision because he didn't have a
look for a shot he's he's underneath the
basket right now
so he scoops right over to justice
who's got the angle
oh okay tv go get it go get him